warum aber warum jetzt das habe ich
getan wird als habe ich mach nix hallo
ich meine lieben freunde willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge picklapp mehr
zusammen mit gomez de la salle china
deshalb eine schöne schöne hilfe die tür
da wir waren hier stehengeblieben bei
bäume im park wirklich ja wirklich
glücklich silvana bucher war slow ist
offen
was möchtest du antwort de einloggen
oder möchtest du antworten beeindrucken
mit ich schlag dich immer runter ja ich
fürchte eine antwort einloggen und dann
ist die antwort populistischen gründen
mode übrigens so geschafft aber wo soll
ich denn jetzt hin
doch links links lang kommentar ist ein
holzsteg darauf und dann also dann hier
man muss man hier so drüber jumpen denke
ich neues pactual du bist heute richtig
gut hier informieren
richtig motiviert ich glaub ich steh ich
hab so ein paar pvp videos auf youtube
angeguckt ich glaube ich habe jetzt
richtig bock auf pvp stemmen das ganze
ein bisschen diesen fv ein bisschen
höher und so was alles hilfe videos
angeschaut ja so von von am gestern
nacht schlafen hat der mord ich will
aber jetzt schlafen ja von so
amerikanern und so wie diese sind so was
alles lacht die sonne genossen und wie
hey wo ich werde und jetzt will ich
erstmal baff im monat auf den baum und
ich weg ist und es sind zwei gas drehen
drin und ich hab jetzt sehen
und ich hatte zwischen pack drin sondern
einfach mal das doppelte
so ist das richtige texten wo bist du
hier gekommen von hier vorne oder von
hier von der seite vom as rom
ich will mir gekommen von da bist du
gekommen wirklich jeder junge jetzt rief
jetzt habe ich leuten schalter ist ein
ernst und scheitern sollten wir weiter
junge warum schickst du mich denn rund
zu hart hol mich wieder hochaltar sie
ist dass wir runtergekommen
so bin ich gekommen weil sein darauf und
es geht weiter was steht ihr checkpoint
41 herr jungen gefunden
im gastraum gefunden ich habe zwei
stücke von wassers ab genug warst du
kannst du nicht hast du hast genug und
ich habe mir die erarbeitet hat einmal
hole ich bring dich um mio
heute ist alles mal an einem lauf hätte
ich auch geschafft
du bist doch ich wollte auch gerade
runterfahren
was denn bitte mich das nicht kalt
bitte port mich nicht wenn du mich jetzt
wortes
du läufst noch junge es immer so beim
ersten bvb jahr angefangen richtig
schreibt meine kommentare werde
kommissarisch inne klare werden da sie
eigentlich die zwischen städtischen und
sprung sprung war das interface
wahrscheinlichsten oder wahrscheinlich
ist da vielleicht auch was drin das ist
nur tarnung dass dann die vor alter die
sprünge sind hier so einfach und ich
verhehle einfach mal trotzdem weil du es
schlecht ist so tepco heute hat es
gesehen ich hab auf den checkpoint drauf
gedrückt steht auch im angriff steht
auch dass du ein checkpoint platz acht
ja geil ich sehe da steht so lux cool
basis auf die schalter explodiert
ein mensch mit einem großen runden lang
oder leonie besser nicht oben womit
könnte herauskommen damit ein gericht im
bh leute ich hab schon wieder auf den
checkpoint gedrückt so und du machst es
mittlerweile auch richtig gewahrt ist
ab/bis und steht auch wirklich steht
konkret das checkers bonpoint natürlich
höher nämlich auf meine community dazu
komme der seine community immer schön
seine rockszene fresse steckt nacht
würde ich natürlich sofort da steht ja
no go find rolle ob man jetzt holt uns
nur warum jetzt habe ich gefallen als
ich mach nix und wir sind hier auf der
ultimate troll habe wollte mich jetzt
mal übernehmen weil die ganzen leute
aber wir sind doch hier auf eine
ultimate rallye map da muss immer noch
ein monatlicher ultimate rollen ist so
eigentlich ein alter alter alter wo user
natürlich entging walter etwas so klug
es war solo und verfassung sind so
laboren [ __ ] alte ich muss jetzt
einfach so lustig aus 100% musstest du
auch noch mal den link hochspringen pilz
musstest du nochmal den pilz
hochspringen nicht von check point
eine runde mitleid noch eine ich möchte
zwei bis die du musst doch bot wo sind
die ganzen boote eigentlich für brote
wir brauchen hier keinen bruch wir sind
von hinten kommt stimmt dann wollen wir
natürlich ein punkt wo wir denn hier los
fahren
ein bisschen rum rollen ich bin gleich
schon da junge kombi der sommer sein
maul halten eltern
ich konnte ich nicht da ich bin gleich
ich bin gleich da
wir fahren jetzt los
die epische fahrtbeginn
ich habe schon gehört mir geile fahren
born in the usa hätten eine alte halter
deutschland ich komme da nicht mehr hoch
wegen der fifa melden gestoppt haben ich
war den ganzen weg wieder zurück egal
leute dann fahren wir sonntag so ich
wollte hier mal ein paar schlimm ist wie
komme ich nie hoch scheiße glaubt mir
steht diesmal keine aufregung
ich finde wirklich hoch sei das
geschafft haben es geschafft
woher hast du dich ganz einfach sie habe
ich gefunden mal von der folge alter
freund farm jawohl ich weiß nicht wo ich
bin
ducati ich warte immer halt seine mutter
und sein partner höher wie bisher schon
wieder ein check und elton john cusack
und war da unten hier oben ist auf einer
okay
so ich bin hier so wie du mich schon
gefragt
ich habe schon leute das geahnt oder
jacobs dem drama spielen könnte
eventuell kommt das teilt ja sollten wir
beide mal aufnehmen mit anderen oder ich
habe auch mal bock drauf und ich nämlich
schon sagtest du eventuell liegen die so
was machen oder allerdings einer anderen
web da könnte ja meinen kommentar
schreiben was ist da so alles gibt
die com ist ganz nett mich an
unterbrechen leute sind überall über
neid aber ganz und gar nicht so viele
körper wie das bourne spawn ja auch noch
direkt neben uns junge beeilt ich komme
als portal 10
das geht einfach mal rein der der
plockstraße in jeder unterschrift auf
mega so waren bei popstars bei cops and
robbers genau dass wir hätten der ebase
bock drauf weil er ja mal da kann man
nichts machen können komm schon deswegen
hätten wir gedacht dass wir uns
eventuell da tipps oder karten der sehr
viele verschiedene einfach mal in die
crunch time könnte
die könnten dann daraus ein kolleg ohne
hd abenteuer machen
ein crooner hd von der hg cops and
robbers zu zweit dass man entsprechende
scheiße mit 53
das jetzt alles erstmal einen rang check
point nicht einfach mal sage ich schaffe
es in einem run und wie es in meinem job
als die harten sprüngen halt dein maul
alten maul danke mittel scheiße
vom chips kommt nicht los gilt nicht
gilt mich gilt mit dann spontan los die
er geil jetzt über junge dieser marc
maslaton will mich doch echte fans des
diagramms land will ein mode rollen ich
finde den weg dich wahrscheinlich dollar
stores wirklich hierüber jungen ich hab
nen halbes herzlos level mich töten
jahre übt ich will dich töten kommen
rüber
ich wohne direkt neben ihren krise
schuldig leute bei ihm auf jeden fall
er ist leiter okay ja genau hier ist
born einfach nochmal paar körper ja
genau so hier an sondern am alter du
hast doch auch noch das blaue schwert
oder das hat die ganze zeit nur du hat
den lockt jetzt richtig ab ob ich gerade
erst entdeckt ich hab' ich hab den
löffel du meintest diesen loreena einen
ollie nein ich meine das blaue schwert
her bin ich überhaupt richtig ja bis
club lavo langen jetzt da fordert erich
sich schon in arm mitten drauf oder
genau ollé ollé halt dein maul neue
leute mit dir wirklich schön drin hab
ich hab's geschafft jammern so und ich
auch sofort never looked okay
lore lay down wir dürfen die nach links
gucken wo ich weiß auch warum ja darum
lauf hast du weißt und einer nacht
totlaufen könnte von mir gebaut so
hommel auf
nein hier einfach ins wasser ins wasser
keine ahnung
da muss doch irgendwo bauer und ich sehe
die mapbox berlin will ich ja wohin
hier ist kein wasser das ist da
irgendwie hinter dem kubaner wenn man
spontan kann auf diese art blog hier
irgendwie raus springen wo ich dann acht
da lange er da genau da darf man nicht
nehmen man die sommertour als schutz
nämlich herunter haben wir ohne leid
über seine auf der linken seite
vielleicht sollte auch eigentlich lange
wenn wir da oben noch stecken haben
damit bekommen leiter sein
hier ist aber auch wirklich bin grad
zurück gelaufen und hiervon rückweg ist
wirklich gar nichts und ich muss man den
sound etwas leiser drin weil die leute
handel aber glaube ich lange ich glaube
mein ich glaub man konnte man kommt da
lang wie denn
doch stimmt wer noch beinahe kann darauf
gekommen
ja aber oder doch bleibe ich muss nur
ein
lena ich bin auch so in gegen gesprungen
so johanna naja man kann es schaffen
glaube ich hoffe ich
der junge mann konnte einfach rein und
das erste was man hört ist kann man
glaube ich nicht schaffen oder was ist
das kölner block ist das 1
wir machen mal auf das aramis sollte
vielleicht mal öffnen geht das dann
seine server ich eröffne das jetzt aber
ich habe fast wieder zugemacht und dann
vielleicht wenn man da drin steht
schließen
doch viel zu schwierig da die prüfer
springe ich einfach unter gesprungen ich
bin mega basecamp nase hatte ich gerade
läuft auf jeden fall bei der fans kommt
ist das jetzt gut ist auch noch viel zu
fett
jetzt kann sein dass jetzt gleich mal
ganz viele sterben werde
was muss passieren so blöd ist gerade
einzustellen so jetzt habe ich einen
anderen fokus
beinahe hätte ich es geschafft aber das
geht doch wirklich nicht oder hat man
hier unten ein wasserbehälter so da bin
ich wieder ein
ich glaube das geht nicht ich bin mir
echt der junge mann muss habe ich nicht
mal schlagen da sind ja die ganze zeit
diese blöden krippe aber dann müssen wir
über 100 pro ja das ist mir auch bewusst
glaube ich dass man dahinter muss
da muss ich musste mich schlagen ein
möchte ich mein fach überschlagen er
macht erzählt dann stelle ich mal drauf
ich muss die partei erwarte ich bin da
ich bin da du musst würde ich darüber
laufe mich schlager los
schade ja du warst ein bisschen zu
schnell weil ich komme einfach wieder
ich verteidige ich hier oben da bin da
bin nachlaufen
der kommt man gar nicht über glaube ich
einfach nochmal noch mal normal wenn man
noch x mal okay okay ich bin springt
einfach zehn mal aber nicht auf der ok
man kann jetzt nicht schaffen das geht
auch gar nicht weil du kannst auch gar
nicht zwischen zwei apple bleiben kannst
du kannst du nicht zwischen weil der
block ist ja teil block hoch weil fast
gleich zwischen den charakter gebaut
portal beim besten willen nicht rüber
guck mal da kann man wirklich nichts
drüber weil der block hat eine tolle
mannschaft halt wirklich nicht aber
montag muss man auch nicht weil da unten
waren wir schon mal bei dem eis park um
junge verstehe ich nicht
wahrscheinlich stehen wir gerade
wirklich tolle lösung aber finden müssen
auf jeden fall da hinten her da wollen
wir die spawn einfach abbauen
ja genau aber jetzt kommt lieber hinter
mich entspannt
nicht in der luft bevor ich fertig bin
hier ja was sage ich verteidige mich
macht okay es bringt mich wozu sollte
ich vielleicht nehme ich denn die vom
wegschlagen nicht zu schlagen
die sport aber hinter dir jetzt
vielleicht erst leicht kaputt war
junge wieder ein lautes endete gestern
nicht normal null der erstes kaputt und
müssen auf jeden fall hinter dir ja okay
ich jetzt einfach vor dem zweiten jung
jetzt sehen mich aber die ganzen kommt
in der luft und verteidige die spanier
alle alten machtverhältnissen schlag
weiter komme er war ja klar ich glaube
man kann es schaffen wenn man auf die
die eher platte springt möchte entlassen
das schafft man nicht leute
normalerweise werde auch kein holz her
stimmt new york no na gut leute ich
würde sagen macht was ihr braucht es gar
nicht in die kommentare schreiben weil
wir noch zufolge auf oder daraufhin
einen und schon ist das thema ganz gut
an
das geht nicht es geht wir gehen nicht
aber es musste das stimmt es muss ihm
wie gehen zu not wollen wir dann einfach
ein spot spart durch kommentare die hand
jetzt werden wir dann eh schon jetzt
anders melden welt gegeben und dann
tschüss bis zum nächsten mal wenn es
kalt ist die gerne ein daumen hoch da
lassen und dann ich bin jetzt begleitet
von dem cooper stu geschafft das jetzt
ich hab sogar geschafft
ja genau nein habe ich nicht wer gut
danach haut rein schönen tag noch und
schön mit